so in my head I feel like I'm a
transgender female to male but also like
a drag queen that's high that's kind of
how I've like rationalized it in my head
Trisha Paytas coming out as transgender
on YouTube and making a lot of people
confused I was shocked I was a little
bit offended I was a little bit confused
I was a lot confused you are not alone
GG so let's just back it up
Trisha posted a 15 minute vlog talking
about gender identity on Monday called I
am transgender female to male I want to
talk about this because it's something
that I actually have felt for a long
time now the video is just a stream of
consciousness and kind of goes all over
the place listen to this part so do I
think I'm transgender yes a thousand
percent do I identify with my natural
born gender a thousand percent so I
think that's where I'm at that bit had
viewers asking a lot of questions and
calling the video out as clickbait in
the comments Trish has been known to
post troll videos before about changing
race coming out as gay and other things
which has led to Trisha getting
cancelled over and over again I feel
like the whole internet thinks I am
about off the ledge but I'm like I'm out
of blood I'm like this way you always
bounce back from just about anything
it's been over it what over ten years of
youtube we've seen you go through with
so many apps so many downs that we
always see you come back yes but Trisha
says this time it's not a lie I don't
think you have to just hide what gender
you are I don't think you have to
announce what gender you are I think we
can be a transgender person without
having the judgment of oh you're not
trans enough you're not transition
enough you're not possible you're not
undetectable like that kind of stuff and
GG gorgeous who popped up earlier says
we should believe Trisha so on the phone
with Trisha the transgender label was
confirmed and I found out that the video
was not clicked
the video was not shock value that
trisha is transgender and i heard that
on the phone talking to trisha yeah GG
who's been super open about her own
transition called up trisha to figure
out what was really going on what i
found out through the years through my
journey is that being transgender is who
you are
it's your soul it's not about how you
look I firmly believe that when someone
tells you who they are what their label
is how they want to be identified you
have to believe that person
Trisha said I am a transgender man and
that is exactly how I will be when we're
sure there will be lots of updates from
Trisha in the coming days so stick with
ET as we keep track of Trish's journey
that's it for now I'm Katie Krauss and
I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]